[Music]
[Music]
okay welcome back
ladies and gentlemen and what seems like
an
astronomical length of time since i last
spoke to today's
guest i'm happy to inform you that i
am rejoined by dr brian
keating now for anyone who hasn't heard
of brian before
he is a chancellor or the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics
at the center of astrophysics and space
sciences
in the department of physics at the
university of california
san diego public speaker inventor
and an expert in the study of the
universe's oldest
light the cosmic microwave background
and he uses that
to learn about the origin and evolution
of
the universe now brian is a writer and a
podcaster and you can catch him
every tuesday i believe a new video goes
up over on youtube
this is one of the best youtube channels
i watch ladies and gentlemen if you're
into science
and i imagine if you're watching this
show and you follow me
you probably are you need to be
following brian because he gets on some
of the best
guests from the science world he's also
a best-selling author
as well we spoke about his book before
losing
the nobel prize well he's back with us
today
he's got a lot to say about galileo and
i can't wait to catch up with this guy
so without any further ado
brian welcome back on to the show and
then like i was saying to you beforehand
since we last spoke it feels like we're
now living in the space age
how you doing brother i'm doing good
i've been
been keeping entertained by watching you
and all the great awesome stuff you're
doing in this
multiverse of minds that we're
connecting together on the internet
you know someday my dream is to like
meet you in person i've so many people
i've been blessed to meet
over the last year of pandemic podcasts
and you know only about maybe 10 percent
have i ever met in person it's
crazy so it's kind of been an
opportunity it's kind of been
a you know a challenge to everybody
on earth some much more than others but
um
i hope we're going to get through it
soon and be on the other side and
meet up in real life because that's what
that's what the world's about it's not
about these
two-dimensional you know black mirrors
that we stare into
or talking to so looking forward to uh
to another great chat today brother
absolutely and i would rather come to
your location
definitely a far sunnier climbs than it
is over here brian button
now i'm you know i suppose we should
really be
grateful that all of this has happened
at a time when we can
connect like this brian right yeah i
mean just
you know five years ago you know someone
was saying
i think online somewhere was like yeah
if this happened lockdown happened
five years ago i would have killed
myself because there was no netflix
or it hadn't you know scaled up the
level it is now
zoom hadn't really you know gotten to
the pinnacle of of its
of its capabilities as it is now youtube
etc so
i don't think people have killed
themselves i mean i think i think
there's uh there are other things to do
in life than just kind of
maximize your use of technology
but by the same token you know it has
been an amazing tool
i actually am candid about it on my
podcast i got my start
you know almost uh almost about a year
ago with my first real podcast
i started off the year with 100
subscribers 2020 and ended it with close
to 20 000
over that now and and trying to really
emulate you and the other pro
youtubers that show how quality
how um kind of not ever underestimating
your audience you
never dumb it down and that's what i
respect about you i never
want to do that i always want to keep it
high level because i feel
as a scientist i have a i have a moral
obligation to spread the knowledge of
science and that's what
i've been focusing a lot on lately is
what do we learn from science
what should we trust science to do for
us
should we put blind faith in science and
scientists
is there a healthy degree of skepticism
how do you balance
you know the truth versus you know this
pursuit of truth which is provisional
skeptical
all the time and so those are questions
i'm grappling with and yeah i've been
blessed to have on some of the
some of the most brilliant people in the
world and uh and
and it's it's growing it's growing uh as
fast as the universe is expanding
you know you talk about galileo and i
want to get into that but
it's quite interesting because we're
talking about 400 years ago
and you would think that we would be a
lot more civilized a lot more advanced a
lot
more intelligent today did i say it
however when i look around the world
brian it feels to me like skepticism
has maybe gone too far and you talked
about a balance there you know
it's almost like we're back in a time
now or we're approaching a time where
where anything scientific is met with
too much skepticism in my opinion
but what do you say to that where have
we gone wrong have we got too much
information at our fingertips now
i don't think it's that i think it's
that my colleagues many of whom
are unwilling unable and really
perhaps incompetent to spread the truth
of the gospel of science
and that doesn't mean science is always
right in fact it's usually wrong
and that's the job of a good scientist
but what we do is a terrible job
we say oh yes you're right when you
think of us as geniuses
you're right and you cultivate an air of
invincibility of intellectual
invincibility now it's not to say that
someone with no scientific training
can come up to me and just revolutionize
all of cosmology
all of astrophysics no not at all you
need to have
a background uh you need to have studied
the history
the technology the pace of growth of
knowledge
in this field of science whatever your
field may be
but i think it's kind of the opposite
you know people scientists spend so much
of our time
studying in the lab communicating
if at all you know the old joke about
scientists is how do you know a
scientist is outgoing
because he looks at your shoes when he
talks to you and
from my perspective you know scientists
have um
some mythology associated with us but we
cultivate it
and uh we do so at our peril because uh
we
in america we have a concept of
separation of church and state which is
a great thing
we don't have a theocracy here we don't
have rule
by unelected you know clerics and we
don't also have to worry about
the government coming down and telling
us what we may or may not do in church
synagogue
mosque etc however we always say
that separation of church and state is
good
for the church it's not only good for
the state to not have this theocratic
rule but it's good for the church
because now they can operate without
coercion
by an all-powerful government those are
great things and i i
i love that about america i love my
country so much however
i think nowadays we've come to a
situation where we have
a need for the separation of science and
state
we have a problem which is that funding
is
is trickled out in ever decreasing
amounts
to a very small cadre of scientists
who have uh deeply uh
you know built up connections and and in
some cases were very well deserved
uh but nevertheless the innovation the
outsiders thinking
the beginners mindset the zen mindset
is not really flourishing the way it
once did
back in the times of people like galileo
so i'm on a crusade to mix metaphors
to get separation of scientist and state
we should have support of science we
should be
free of government overlords telling us
what we should research
and part of that begins with not letting
the government use
our research for its own purposes to
advance a political agenda
that we were never elected to do very
very well said brother well said you
mentioned the church
there and that brings us nicely into
galileo we've been talking about a lot
lately
i learned a lot from listening to just
one podcast that you were on
within prager university i had always
been under the belief that this was one
of the most persecuted characters in the
whole
history talk to us about galileo brian
and what it is that you really um look
up to in him
uh i love galileo he's my uh number one
hero of science you know people venerate
einstein
you ask who did einstein venerate he
venerated galileo
in fact galileo was the first physicist
really of the modern age he was the
first observational astronomer to use a
telescope
and he was the first person to come up
with a concept of relativity
how do you gauge the motion of various
uh observers as they go out in their
business and travel at different
velocities underneath a boat as he
talked about in a
in a uh the hold of a ship all the way
to earth flying around in the air how do
you
judge their uh scientific contributions
galileo is held in the highest esteem
by none other than the person that most
of us think of when we think of the
genius
and that's albert einstein what's great
about galileo is like einstein is like
me
as like you kev he was a man uh he was a
human
and he had great flaws he had great
ideas
brilliant ideas but he had brilliant
blunders as well
and some of those impelled him to do
things that were not scientific
and it goes to show if someone as bright
as galileo
can make certain mistakes can make
blunders
called confirmation bias trying overly
hard
to justify a hypothesis that he had
coined or created himself
which was correct uh in in truth but the
evidence for which he presented
was absolutely flawed and known now to
be a great blunder
if someone as great as him can make a
mistake
so too can a schmuck like me make a
mistake
uh you know as i have been and as i have
done
and it shows you just the power of
mistakes and as i write about in my book
losing the nobel prize
it's okay to lose most people lose we
just had the super bowl last night
in america well uh there's like 50 guys
who are like
total shack diesel i mean these guys are
huge brothers i mean they are
amazing and i look they're the most
elite athletes in the world and you know
what they lost
they're losers right no they're not
losers
unless they don't learn from what they
did not do to to
create a victory for themselves now in
science there's no absolute victory we
can never win
football american football you guys call
it
is a zero-sum game one wins one loses
however science i've been talking about
this a lot
science is the infinite game there's no
winners or losers
and the good thing is we can always uh
win battles
we can never win the war we can win the
battles
because our enemy is mother nature and
she is always in retreat
she may have an infinite army that's
powerful beyond all human
comprehension but we can make progress
every single day
such that even a failure like i made
many many of them
or galileo has as well they lead
to future battles and future victories
uh we just might not be alive to see
the fruits of our particular labors but
that's okay
so brian you mentioned that his um
evidence or the way he got there was
kind of flawed
and what do you mean by that what what
did he do wrong how hard was it for
him to get his ideas across back then
well i talk about galileo a lot also in
my book because
imagine take yourself back to 16 you
know 1630 1621
back then the predominant prevailing
opinion was that the earth was
the center of the universe center of the
solar system
everything else went around us and that
had prevailed for 2
000 years since a man by the name of
aristotle
and ptolemy and others came up with the
idea of the earth-centered universe
so i always like to point out you know
when you hear this words these words in
america we hear them a lot
trust the science trust scientists
well i like to say you know there was a
yeah aristotle was a scientist
it turns out almost everything he said
scientifically
except for i've only found one or two
things he was right about in science
and they're not like you know things
that you use on a daily basis he was the
first person
to scientifically prove that whales were
not
fish okay that's cool that's important
but on the same token uh you know he
also thought that heavy objects fell
faster than lighter ones he thought the
earth was the center of the universe
etcetera etcetera he did much better in
math and poetry and logic
than he ever did in science nevertheless
he was a scientist
and his ideas prevailed for thousands of
years until copernicus
conjectured that the universe was not
centered on the earth it was centered on
the sun
which by the way is wrong also the
universe isn't centered on the sun any
more than it's centered on the earth
it's just more true than saying the
earth is the center of the solar system
it's much more true to say the sun is
this close to the center of the solar
system than not
so what galileo did is he observed the
moons of jupiter
in 16 and 1610 just about
411 years ago this week he discovered
these little stars orbiting around
jupiter which he very sick of
fantastically like a teacher's pet
he named them after his patrons the
medici family
of northern italy but anyway he uh
he he knew that what he had shown was
not that the earth was the center of the
solar
not the solar center of the solar system
all he could show at that observation
with all in quotes
was that the earth wasn't the only
center of the universe he didn't prove
that the sun is the center of the cosmos
so that was left to his next book so in
1610 he produced a book called the
starry messenger
in 1632 even after being forbidden to
publish on this and to teach it
he published another book called the
dialogue on the two chief
world systems but that wasn't its
original title
the original title of the book that
einstein called perhaps the greatest
book in science history
that title originally was
on the flux and reflux of tides
in the earth's rivers lakes and ferns
i don't know what a fern is but maybe
you have some ferns up there in scotland
lots of them over here yeah they make up
our lovely colorful countryside
yeah yes that's lovely yeah so we don't
have too many of them here but
but i'll take your word for it i trust
you implicitly they're pulling
these they're full of like techs and
horrible little beasties you don't want
to get caught in the bird
are there any monsters in there yeah
maybe maybe loch ness just there
so uh so he originally wanted to call it
that weird title
um that title meant that he thought the
tides on the ocean like we have here in
beautiful sunny san diego
uh we have tides twice a day high tides
twice a day low tides
he said that was because the earth
rotates on its axis and
goes around the sun bingo proved it
nailed it
except there's one problem he is
completely
unequivocally uncategorically wrong he
is
completely misguided by this desire to
prove something which is true
namely that the earth is not the center
of the solar system and
it is true that the earth goes around
the sun however the evidence that he
used
so much so that he wanted to title his
book after this
incorrect confirmation bias driven um
title was completely wrong so that's the
that was the kind of morass that he got
into and you know who helped him out
and changed the name of the book to
something much more much more
intriguing and and kind of gripping and
that was the catholic church they said
no call it the dialogue on the two world
systems
and it stayed that way ever since and
many people thought
because of this book he was tortured to
death or you know thrown in jail at the
dungeon with the key tossed away
i've always been under the impression of
you know the darkest horriblest hole
under the vatican
yeah he was not he was allowed to move
not only
back to a palatial villa that is so nice
kev that i held a conference there
in 2015 to discuss what's called
galilean relativity and other phenomena
uh it has great vineyards it has olive
trees
he was able to not only do astronomical
observations
he was not only able to write another
book
very similar to the dialogue which you
know that shouldn't have been impossible
and some say that was his greatest
contribution to physics was his last
book called the discourse
on two new sciences sounds very similar
right so
you know i don't see in america you know
we've got you know bernie madoff and
you've got all these you know these
awful people and they're in like
you know solitary confinement or jeffrey
epstein
you know uh you know they're they're
putting these spider holes
this guy was put in a place so luscious
so lovely
uh that it has a view of you know
overlooking uh downtown florence
and not only that they permitted him to
live very close to his beloved daughters
who were nuns in a nunnery uh about a
kilometer away from his prison
so he was treated pretty uh pretty
fairly i would say
and by no means was he tortured it seems
to me almost like the vatican came
in and took over where the medicis left
off
it sounds like they gave him the perfect
kind of them life
so he could concentrate and think about
his next book you know
and you know from my story you know that
i'm jewish but i was actually raised
catholic
and i was actually an altar boy in the
catholic church and one of the things
that always appealed to me about the
catholic church is that they operate the
vatican
operates a huge telescope and and this
telescope called the vatican observatory
it's like three meters across it's an
enormous telescope
why are they interested in it because
they believe that they can get a window
into the mind of god or jesus christ or
whatever by exploring the world around
us via nature
now it wasn't like the pope back then by
the way the pope urban the eighth was
very educated and actually had been
tutored by galileo at some point
and they were friends and the only thing
that that the that the church had told
him in 1616 so 16 years before he
published the dialogue
as he said they said you can't teach
the theory of our of of the earth not
going or going around the sun
you cannot teach that what you must do
is only teach
you must only study it but not teach it
and by that they meant that you could
only write about it in scholarly
you know journals or magazines or books
or whatever and that meant
writing in latin as i discussed and
losing the nobel prize
he took it on his own authority that he
could then
violate that order he would not only do
research
he would not only learn about it but he
would teach it
and by teaching he would publish not in
latin as the starry messenger was which
is called sidirius nuncius
and i know you speak fluent latin every
day yeah yeah but uh i had to look that
up
uh but but he wrote the dialogue their
title is the dialogue it's written
in italian the popular vernacular of the
day
therefore he was teaching and that they
couldn't stand by and imagine you
imagine if like
you kev know for sure that um
that there's this this pandemic and it's
coming to kill everybody on earth
and uh and only you can protect against
it
and you have this true knowledge and
you're guaranteed and super sure
you would almost be morally obligated to
tell
everybody in the most stringent of terms
to um to you know be safe to take care
of themselves whatever wear masks you
know take this do them
and um so the vatican had an obligation
this was like an existential threat
to their security and to their stability
so you know i'm not a huge fan of of
what they did and they actually never
pardoned him officially so i don't want
to
come off saying the vatican is flawless
and so forth they just said that they
removed this this
suspicion of heresy which was actually
granted in a way to not allow not force
him to be tortured if they said he was
heretical
he would have been tortured i actually
made a mistake when i gave my ted talk
i gave a ted talk about galileo and uh
and you can find online
and but you know it wasn't only about
galileo was kind of the precursor to my
book back in 2014.
and in this story uh in my ted talk i
start off by saying imagine if the
greatest mind of
of his day stephen hawking the late
great stephen hawking
was thrown in jail for thought crimes
and i put this like bar slamming shot on
it
so i was wrong i actually didn't know
that he hadn't been put in an official
jail and here i am a professional
scientist you know
in love with galileo so how much more so
can the general public
be be misled that galileo is a martyr
for science
against the evil indoctrinating catholic
church it's just not true and so
part of my love affair with this book
the dialogue that i'm going over
and some exciting news for your
listeners uh
is that that book the dialogue had a
huge effect not only on me
you know some nobody but einstein
stephen j gould
the greatest minds in history after
galileo and isaac newton
but um but no one's ever made an e-book
like a
kindle or whatever pdf version of it and
no one's ever made of the definitive
translation of it
and no one's made an audio book of it so
i kind of took it on myself as an
homage to find out if i could get the
rights to publish this book as an audio
book for the very first time
and the audiobook rights are owned by my
home university university of california
and so i went back in the uh the
definitive translation by a man by the
name of stillman drake
professor at uc berkeley our neighbors
to the north here and i secured the
uh the the rights to make the first
audiobook and i'm doing it in
consultation in combination
with several italian physicists
including just recently
i got carlo rovelli i don't know if you
know who he is he's
one of the most famous physicists yeah
so he's
yeah he's gonna read the uh he's gonna
read the
introduction from galileo in as italian
beautiful italian accent
so stay tuned for that that's gonna take
me a while to do but
in the meantime i'm doing stuff uh with
carlo revelli on the into the impossible
podcast which is on
all major podcast uh venues as well as
my youtube channel dr brian keaney
yeah that sounds absolutely awesome and
you know listening to you talking about
galileo there then
it's almost like he was one of the first
whistleblowers
because he made it he almost made the
information available to people that
would never
it was never intended for right that's
right you know the italian and
the vatican was so powerful it was uh it
was sort of an empire
you know which had scientific emissaries
and and like i said earlier
it wasn't like aristotle wasn't a
scientist he was a scientist so do you
trust him
i i have a problem with that notion of
trust when it's used as a shorthand for
obey in other words if i say trust you
know if i'm your doctor i say trust me
you've got you know uh you know stage
one
lump on your on your backside you better
listen you know you better trust but you
know
do you just trust or do you get a second
opinion well what about in a case where
you don't
have an opportunity like where do you
get a second opinion about wearing masks
from
i mean how do you do that um and i wear
a mask obviously
but you know we had conflicting
information we just had a study i read
in nature that just came out
that said it's it's not super effective
to
uh to wipe down surfaces for prevention
i'll just say of certain
uh types of viruses okay i'm not gonna
speak specifically
so you know but my wife every time she
goes to supermarket she
wipes down hoses down disinfects
chlorinates you know does whatever on
every piece of fruit
everything and you know is it is it
gonna do any harm
no but um but my point is you know when
you listen to scientists
uh in a way that you obey us um when
i tell you about a black hole in a
distant galaxy it's not gonna affect
your life cow
it might inspire you you might like it
but it's not going to dominate you it's
such that if you don't obey me
you could have some negative
repercussions so i worry about that when
there are scientists especially like
leaders of scientific guilds and
countries or epidemiologists in your
country
who'll come out and say something based
on a model and maybe this is useful for
us to discuss i haven't really talked
about this much
but um there's a difference in between a
theory when i say to you kev
um you know uh the evolution is a theory
what does that mean what what do you
think that means i'm going to turn it
out i'm going to
at the end i'm going to ask you some
questions by the way from my podcast kev
i hope it's okay
now would that not be if it's a theory
it's not is
it not something that you can replicate
and you can
test time and time again and get the
same outcomes
well it's not that no etherean science
is about as clear-cut
slam-dunk you know evidence-proven fact
that we can be
you can never be completely 100 percent
sure of a given scientific fact for
example um
if you say the earth is flat you know it
looks flat but
uh but then there's evidence that it's
flat but actually and actually there's
way more evidence
that it's flat then it's spherical just
to your eyes uh but we won't get into
that
please don't say that please don't say
that you oh no you don't want to go
there
okay i'm not gonna go there uh but
there's evidence but visual evidence
don't be led astray as the bible says by
what your eyes make you prostitute to
okay i'm not gonna get into that
um but if you you know what if you say
the earth is a sphere
you're also complete you're also wrong
yeah you're wrong because it's not a
perfect sphere it has a squishiness it
has a bulge at the equator from rotating
around
it has tidal force anyway it's not a
perfect sphere uh and so
but you're less wrong than if you say
it's flat and so science is always
provisional in the sense that you come
along and correct things that are in the
past
so you'll never be able to say that the
theory of evolution is the same as the
pythagorean theory
you know which is proven in mathematical
terms to the extent that you can prove
something self-consistently
as kirk girdle showed is incomplete but
nevertheless
you can prove it to a mathematical
degree of certainty there's no such
degree in physics that you can do that
but
to the best of our knowledge the theory
of gravity theory of relativity has
has been proven beyond a shadow of a
doubt so when someone says to you that's
just a theory
that is actually very high praise it's
it's actually saying about as much as
you can possibly say the theory of
evolution
is as true as a scientific fact can be
measured to be true now of course
there'll be corrections to it
as we know uh but uh but then there's a
difference between a theory
which has been observed makes
predictions confronted
with uh new facts and data and then
built up consensus
around there's a difference between that
and a model
a model is a prediction of the future
based on
perhaps a theory combined with some
observations
so you know predicting the future is
pretty hard to do if you haven't noticed
and so uh you might want to you know be
skeptical of
models that make you uh obey certain
behaviors and certain
you know so you had this famous thing in
your country and models predicted to be
two million people dead you know bubba
and all this stuff and then it did not
come to pass
now the question is what happens to
those scientists what happens to those
politicians
who mandate certain behaviors based on
models not based on theories you know if
they say
you know the vaccines are safe it's
proven this way from the
theory of evolution or dna structure you
should trust that
but if they say we predict that if you
don't do x y and z
that so many people will die because
fundamentally you cannot
falsify that you cannot prove that wrong
because it occurs in the future
and so i have problems with global
warming people when they talk about
models of what's going to happen
i don't i believe that man is causing
global warming i believe it in the core
of who i am as a scientist
there's multiple directions of evidence
etc but where i bar
part ways is when those models predict
how i should change my behavior
and how the world should alter its
behavior i bring up this example
that the number one problem in wall
street the
center of financial power on the planet
100 years ago
120 years ago uh was was
uh horse crap they traders couldn't get
into the stock exchange because the
streets were filled with manure
there was bacteria there are parasites
it was like a very dangerous place to go
to work
it's still dangerous but for different
reasons we won't get into uh but
nevertheless
and so imagine you're back then you're
like we gotta find a solution to this or
the models predict all the traders will
die in 10
years and we won't get to have the great
depression uh
and they say well we're going to make
horse diapers and we're going to make
you know
self scooping or horse no that wasn't
the cure
that wasn't the solution it was
innovation and
so too do i hope that we already know
there are ways to innovate our way out
of global warming
and it's called nuclear power there's
there's high efficiency turbines
wind turbines uh there's natural gas
there's many ways we can avert it
delay it postpone it flatten the curve
of global warming
and what i want to worry about is that
people are not going to believe in
global warming
because they're going to say you guys
made up all this stuff about about masks
not helping and then mask we're helping
and then like washing surfaces
and then it doesn't matter if you wash
it so why should we believe you about
something that we know to be happening
like global warming i'm very afraid
about that
so you know be careful when someone
tells you to change things based on a
model
of what could possibly happen and be
very
um be very much more open when they talk
about something that's theoretically
uh possible and has a lot of evidence
for a hypothesis that's
essentially been verified just always
think about the theory of evolution or
the theory of gravity
yeah it's a strange time for science
brian it truly is but
i was going to ask you what are you
looking forward to
from an astrophysics kind of point of
view in the year 2021 because
there's a lot of space stuff happening
dude a lot of space stuff
yeah what's so cool is that we're
getting on my podcast i'm getting people
i've had nine nobel prize winners come
on and talk about their research
and the thing that really exemplifies
you know the nobel prize spirit to me
and i'm actually writing in my second
book
is going to be called um winning the
nobel no it's going to be called
[Laughter]
think it's going to be called think like
a nobel prize winner
and it's going to be the tools and
tactics and tricks that these great
minds
uh that you're showing up there on the
screen right now have used to
overcome and and battle through
obstacles and challenges they're human
beings too
and uh and if you and if you want to
learn from the best and brightest
these are the people to look to and so
how do they come about it and they're
as passionate as they have ever been
about
unraveling the mysteries of as as we're
talking about
the fundamental composition of the
universe
so on the screen now it's like frank
wilcheck just to the right of the of the
arrow right now
he won the nobel prize in 2004. this is
an amazing guy
uh barry barrish won the nobel prize and
and and
ray weiss i've had them on and these
guys have overcome so much
waiting till their 80s you know from the
time that they invented something maybe
in their 30s 40s 20s in the case of
frank wilcheck and how do they persevere
how do they endure how do they have the
resilience to do that and the thing that
keeps them going is a passion for the
science
so for me i'm very passionate about uh
potentially unraveling
the imprint of a universe that might
have existed not definitely
by no means is there evidence yet for
doing this but there could have been a
universe that existed before our
universe
and steve and uh stephen hawking believe
this in some sense
sir roger penrose who won the nobel
prize i'm speaking at his 90th birthday
party in august
about ways that we can prove or perhaps
more accurately prove him wrong
that's what science does we prove people
wrong is there another universe before
ours
that's the question i'm trying to answer
wow now and
so i'm thinking about this in my mind
here
are we talking about some kind of
inflation
and then deflation and then something
starts or
how are you kind of looking at it brian
yeah there's multiple ways that you
could
have universes that cycle in and out of
existence in time
you could have multiple universes that
cycle into and out of existence in space
and you can combine those together in
multiple universes in both time and
space and space time
and how do you reconcile that with the
with the passage of time
with the with the laws of physics that
we observe
and so these are different concepts
known as the multiverse in either space
or time or the absence of the multiverse
so we're looking at things like
inflation like conformal cyclic
cosmology
like something julian barbour's talked
about the janus point
you know time comes into existence um
and so these are are truly fascinating
subjects for me to study
and we think now with the technology
we're building in the simon's
observatory and the high atacama desert
at 5 000 meters above sea level in
northern chile we might
be able to in the next construction will
hopefully
uh be be finished this year and we'll
start observing it with some of our
telescopes
on this high altitude plateau in the
drive desert on earth trying to find
wispy imprints of a pr of a previous
early epoch in our universe that
produced waves of gravity that ripple
throughout
our cosmos to this very day and so
it's there's never been a more exciting
time and i think this is going to be
cosmology's decade
i think the the the rise of new
telescopes the very reuben observatory
also in chile
the uh space observatories uh the jwst
the successor to hubble
should be launched this year it's been
delayed for decades uh
over a decade uh but hopefully it'll be
this year that launches it and we peer
back just as hubble
showed us this miraculous vistas of the
early
epochs in the universe so too will the
jwst
take us back and reveal new cosmic
information with a greater clarity than
ever conceived about and and what an
exciting time to be
a younger person and have a career
to uh to to probe the deepest depths of
human comprehension and get paid to do
it
yeah we're going through like one of the
darkest periods in our lifetime right
now yet at the same time
for me i'm still very optimistic because
i see a lot of good things happening and
when i was growing up yeah
and i imagine you were the same but you
would probably be thinking the year 2021
we would be uh interplanetary kind of
space fading civilization right
but to me it starts it's feeling like
we're actually now starting to take off
we're actually starting to get there
does it feel like
that to you working in the kind of field
yeah we're definitely reaching this
confluence of
technology of of awareness of science
of um of new
grasping things that your reach cannot
possibly have right now so
interplanetary voyages i talked to avi
loeb
a professor the former chair at harvard
university had a book out
about this object that came near the the
earth in 2017 which he claims is alien
technology
and so not only does he think that alien
technology has visited the earth
he believes that there will be many more
to come
and that with the onslaught of the new
telescopes that i talked about in space
and in
on earth and with the advent of
inexpensive space
travel via so-called cubesats or maybe
solar sails
that we'll be able to visit not only
these objects
as they come close to the earth in our
solar system obviously came from outside
of our solar system
but from where we don't know and so
that's the next step in evolution he's
involved with the project to send
a swarm of tiny cell phone camera lenses
basically attached to sensors to
proxima centauri where we you know claim
some claim we had a
a message transmitted from back in
december i did a podcast with dr jill
tarter who's a friend of mine uh the
inspiration for the ellie
roa character in the movie contact and
uh and she's incredibly fascinating
she's very dubious about that coming
from
an extraterrestrial intelligence but all
these things it's going to be the advent
of astrobiology
you know finding we had uh i had a
podcast with people that said they
detected
signatures of life dr sarah seeger on
the planet venus
not mars but venus yeah and that was
like
in its atmosphere yeah any other yeah
that would have been like
him that would have won prizes for being
like the headline of the year but last
year it kind of got lost by the wayside
right
yeah there was a lot of competing for
attention you know there's aliens
there's
there were uh you know flybys if we go
back to avi for just a moment because
i'm
i see aliens everywhere brian i'm like
yeah
you know i go looking for them but when
i hear somebody like him
coming out and and also the reasoning
behind
why he thinks it was some kind of alien
structure
i tell you what to layman to somebody
who's just interested in science he
makes a pretty compelling case
what do you make of his work yeah i had
a long
conversation with him and he's become a
friend and i have a great deal of
respect for him
uh you know i never believe you know
anything without verification and trying
to con
confirm it so i said to him avi you know
you're involved with this project to
send
little cameras to another solar system
why don't you
take that billion or you know yuri
milner who's funding it
why don't you take ask him for you know
10 million dollars
to send a satellite to omumua which is
this object that he claims came from
another civilization
before it's too late before it gets too
far away and you can't catch up to it
and uh i didn't i didn't like his answer
as much you know
and again this is with utmost respect
but he was like no we'll
we'll wait and there'll be more that
will come when we'll discover many more
as i said with the beer ruben
observatory
with other telescopes doing surveys in
space and you know but there's a concept
that you
you might be you you might you know it
takes a certain set of skill to get
lucky
twice yeah and sometimes you only get
lucky once and what if that was the one
encounter that he'll ever have in his
life and
here's a guy it's not it's not just like
me telling you
kev you know take take all your winnings
you know from the dart game at the pub
and go down it no you can't
he knows a guy who's spending a hundred
million dollars to send a bunch of
cameras to a place that we don't
know has life and if he claims this
actually came from there i mean i would
put everything on that
and so uh but he's incredibly brave he's
taken a tremendous amount of heat
because he has gotten so popular i mean
after he came on
you know so he came on my show and he
went on the joe rogan show and the lex
friedman show
and so between the three of us he got
like three million views so i i take a
lot of credit for that you know
flakes is a good guy like him yeah you
guys he got 3 million
10 000 views you know so i'll let you
guess which of the three of us got the
10 000
but uh but i'm doing you know my thing
there those guys are great
uh but you know he goes on those shows
and what do you think some astronomer
you know who's got no attention who
thinks he's you know
smart or she's as smart as avi and she
or he's not getting any
they're gonna say oh he's not serious
he's going on joe rogan he's going on
lex friedman no
i i think it's it's phenomenal what he's
doing scientists have an obligation to
be
uh to be the chief cheerleaders
proponents
and exponents of what we're doing who
else is going to do it for us so
you know hell yeah if i'm invited on one
of those shows i'm going on it doesn't
mean that
that you know that that's the venue
where science is proven or not
but it's a very callous and jealous
thing to say because he's so popular
and because you know he's gotten so much
attention for this idea
that he's somehow less you know
respected actually there's an article
written by this guy who writes a forbes
magazine
named ethan siegel and ethan wrote this
article
you know criticizing avi and saying you
know
you know that the idea is nonsense and
it's not taking serious that this is
alien
and then he wrote that like he was once
respected
i'm like javi is still you know one of
the most productive
incredibly intel even if this turns out
to be a total hoax or is wrong
he is incredibly respected so much more
so than
you know i'm not going to say the end of
that sentence but but the point is
you know people the higher you fly the
easier you are to shoot down and people
want to take aim at you
he's taking a lot of arrows and he's
incredibly brave
and um you know he's he's he's israeli
and
and i have a lot of friends in my
community israeli and you know they're
not known for the
smooth you know the nickname for
israelis are like cactuses
you know they're not the like warmest
cuddle cuddliest of all folks but um but
he can take it because the cactus has
spikes to protect itself from
from invaders that want a second dry i
must admit i
anki's brilliant i am i i like
that we see scientists going on joe
rogan
i want to get back to time when you know
and young kids are looking at scientists
and making them their heroes
and you know think of how many people
might hear avi and inspire young minds
into going into science that alone you
know
and i think it's ridiculous what that
that kind of journalist was saying
and i tell you it takes some seconds for
somebody with the reputation of avi
to come out and put it all on the line
right because i mean that can't be easy
brian coming out right no and it's
incredibly brave
he is taking a stand you know there's a
saying if you if you stand in the middle
of the road
and this works in the uk too if you stay
in the middle of the road you get hit
from both sides
you know he's taking a side he's
switching you know he's
he's backing it up he's putting all his
credibility on the line there's a guy
chairman of the department of astronomy
at harvard university it's this has not
got to be taken lightly he's taking risk
my friend eric weinstein he does the
same thing
he's not in academia so he has a little
bit more liberty not to do stuff
perhaps without you know fear of not
getting tenure
or or or some repercussions and uh eric
goes on joe rogan you know a couple
times a year
lex friedman the same way he actually
had a son zev weinstein was on
was on lex's show just recently who is a
young man that i have a tremendous
amount of
of respect for and hope for the future
that he gives to me for the young
people of uh of generation z
and uh these are people that are doing
outreach and it takes a lot of courage
but
they're doing it in part they get so
much attention because so few of the
rest of us are doing it and making it a
priority i always say
you know why don't you learn how to do
public speaking to my colleagues
they're like oh it's too hard it's not
my personality i'm like oh yeah i forgot
you know when you were born you knew
quantum electrodynamics
you never had a work at it you never had
to study it or study somebody who was a
master and you acted as apprentice now
you just you just learned it right and
they're like no but it's different i'm
like no it's not different if
you prioritize it like anything else it
could be like your marriage it could be
like with your kids you gotta like read
books
learn from experts process that iterate
make the flywheel turn
and then you become good at it it's not
enough to just say i'm not born that way
i'm gonna
stay inside my academic hermit shell it
might tie back into what we were talking
about earlier
and you know i think if people could
relate more to the science community
that the big names in science it
wouldn't feel like such a closed club
almost like a priesthood you know a
priest class where that's totally
separate from the people on the ground
so um i i think people like yourself
people like you mentioned there
i think you're doing absolutely
brilliant work and connecting or
reconnecting people to the science and
making it interesting again
we're making science interesting again
that's what we're doing
yeah yeah making it great again it
should be it's like
imagine like you're you know you're uh
you're an actor and you're like oh all i
have is shakespeare
no it's awesome we have incredible uh
incredible material and we never use it
and we
and we we allow people to misuse it in
our name and then take credit for it and
we allow people to
conflate you know kind of these these
awe struck you know whatever
and and and missed the opportunity to
make an indelible impression upon young
people
and i feel like that's almost a crime
you know certainly a crime that's
punishable by imprisonment in a
beautiful villa in northern italy
absolutely so listen you work with a lot
of the young scientists i take it i mean
are you encouraged for the future
with what's coming through yeah very
much so i mean you can spot it you can
tell who's gonna make it
i've had 16 graduate students get their
phds are about to get their phds in 17
years
pretty proud of that and none of them
are unemployed and that is a
testament as much to you know kind of
their abilities their intelligence the
gifts that they came in with
but also being open and trainable and
coachable and
learning these skills that aren't
they're not intrinsic nobody's born
being a good speaker
and i realized that when i had some
students from from thailand or china
and that's one of the best things about
being an academic cab is i get to meet
people
i've had students from uganda i've had
students from new zealand and all the
way to you know montana
so it's it's incredible and it's a
privilege and my kids get to meet those
people
you know i get to go to their houses
they get to come to my house and and and
my kids are going to grow up in so much
richer of a culture environment than i
grew up in even though i had a father
who was a professor i mean
we talked about that last time he's uh
this sort of my memoir
is about you know reconciling with his
flaws and and his inadequacies as a
father
he didn't take advantage of that as a
professor i'll be damned if i'm not
going to take advantage of it
expose my kids to the greatest ideas and
other cultures
travel and and and bonding over great
uh great food great wine and i can't
wait to get back to it
uh but but yeah these students give me
hope because
they come in with a passion the other
day i was having i have a meeting every
friday
afternoon going into the weekend you
know we kind of sit around now it's on
zoom unfortunately but but soon we'll be
back in person i hope
and we had some new students come in and
i asked them you know
just like randomly what's your favorite
book what'd you read recently
and they're like a brief history of
string theory and i'm just like holy
crap like these guys are reading string
theory
for pleasure not and these aren't nerds
the other book was like you know ursula
le guin you know some like science
fiction and then some
some like real you know non-fiction you
know malcolm gladwell whatever
and i'm like wow this is impressive this
is a person with curiosity
and if you have curiosity i can take you
as far as you want to go
that's my that's my deepest hope that's
what i do at the arthur clark
center for human imagination that i'm
honored to serve as the co-director of
is we're investigating new modalities to
improve increase
human imagination because it is the most
human of all human
traits and to me uh and if you'll
indulge me in the last couple of minutes
i'd love to
ask you some questions even you've had
me on your show i'm gonna hopefully get
a copy of this and put this on my show
because i want my audience to get to
know you
but i don't know if there are any other
questions before we go what i call into
the impossible
do you have any more things you want to
follow up well i think you've pretty
much covered it let's go into the
impossible man i like it
all right brother so every every show
and i have guests on i'm i'm uh honored
to have on like you
i always ask him uh a series of three
questions i'll start with
with the questions that i ask all of my
get now you didn't have any preparation
for this i just sprung this on you
so i'll give you an extra couple of
seconds so i want to know if you can
construct a conformal field theory that
has
less than eight dimensions but can unify
quantum mechanics with electro weak
force
yeah every day of the week yeah okay all
right good you you
you be frank wilcher it took him 20
seconds that's like
okay but he has a nobel prize so that
okay here we go you're ready
all right the first question i ask you
relates to
you know kind of the theme of the end of
my book uh losing the nobel prize
which is that um it's what you do
outside of the laboratory
that makes a big impact on your friends
and your family
on your culture on your nation and your
world and
uh for me alfred nobel did something
interesting because he endowed the nobel
prize
which came with some cash and everything
but he was never married had no kids
and a lot of my audience is like a lot
of my friends are like that i have no
kids they're not married
and so how do you leave a will not just
monetarily well first of all who do you
leave the money to if you don't have any
errors i mean i'll
i'm open i'll give you my my bitcoin wow
here just in case
either way yeah it works both ways
definitely man
so uh so yeah but my question is what is
what are you gonna put in your ethical
will in other words alfred nobel said
here are these prizes they should only
go to the single person who in the
preceding year
made a physics discovery that had the
greatest
benefit to mankind that was the end of
it so in other words
something material going to something
that is intangible that is heterodox
that is different than just the physical
discovery laws of nature
he said how did you make the world
better what do you kev when you reach
the biblical age of 120 years old
what do you want to put in your ethical
will to tell all of humanity
as a guide for the wisdom that you've
acquired during your time
on earth to
to talk to listen
to each other and not to fall out over
the stupidest little thing
and to enjoy the journey and um perfect
try and help one person every day and by
that you can even just say hello to
somebody
and just ask them how they're doing that
can change somebody's world you can't
change the world
per se but you can change the world for
somebody around you
just by being nice to them you know
that's right
yeah that's the microcosm everyone wants
to change the world have revolution
have you know whatever this and that and
they don't realize that the greatest
impact they can make is on themselves
and uh
yeah i love that that's very stoic i
love it okay the next question is also
going into the future but a lot further
than 120 years from now
instead we're going to go a billion
years from now so there's a movie called
2001 a space odyssey i don't know if you
ever saw it oh yeah
yeah so it's one of my great greatest
movies of all time and and uh certainly
the
my favorite scene did you see the
monolith that turned up last year the
monolith turned up in utah you know
that's about what i'm about to ask you
about so in that movie
the beginning scene for those that
haven't seen it uh has these hominids in
africa and they come upon this monolith
this structure
that's like a time capsule and they
don't know how to interact with it so
they hit it with a bone
they try to like you know push it over
whatever and nothing works
but another you know fast forward couple
hundred thousand maybe a million years
then astronauts encounter it on the moon
and floating around in space so it's
obviously meant to be a time capsule of
some kind we don't know what the purpose
is exactly
it's kind of menacing in that sense uh
but i want to ask you
what what you know idea book
music what would you most like to put on
a billion year lasting time capsule
oh what a fantastic question eh
wow um this podcast
um no i tell you um that's a really
great question
i seriously would need to think about
that i'd say i'm quite profound that
brian
[Music]
[Laughter]
encoding whatever the message was
into stone for argument's sake
something that will last i look at the
pyramids and i think there's still a lot
of secrets encoded in there
almost like a time capsule when we can
release them we'll get them
so um i would do it along those kind of
lines i would leave something that
when we're at a certain level to
actually interpret it to figure out what
it is
whatever that knowledge then contains
would be appropriate for
the level of civilization at that time
interesting okay good very vague
all over the place but it'll do it
sounded interesting
it did sound interesting i liked it you
know i was honored to have on carl
sagan's widow
wow a woman by the name of ann drurion
and she works on the cosmos
uh project with the elder grass tyson
she's an author she wrote the book
contact with carl sagan um who was
obviously
uh you know the the progenitor of many
many young cosmologists including myself
and neil degrasse tyson and others uh
but uh
when i asked her what would you put on
it and she's like oh i already did that
like what the heck are you talking about
she's like well she recorded her brain
waves
on the voyager 1 golden disc that was
sent out
into interplanetary space wow and that
golden disc contains her brain waves and
sounds of earth
and and people talking and and water
bubbling in a brook
on a on a record player you know i'm
just hoping that they'll have a
phonograph needle you know in a billion
years
what would you leave for people what
would you leave
well i always phrase in terms of like
scientific knowledge in terms of what
would you put on the scientific
so i would put a plot showing the
the cosmic microwave background
polarization
spectrum what it looks like because in
order to do that
you have to have done what richard
feynman answered this question he wasn't
on my podcast unfortunately
but uh but he had a great influence on
me and richard feynman said many things
first of all he said one thing that i
quote
all the time which is that science is
the belief in the ignorance of experts
in other words if i tell you this is all
known darwin was right
galileo is right aristotle is right and
you just trust them
then you're never going to do science
science will stagnate st
you know and stand still completely but
if you believe that they're not ignorant
but they don't have all the knowledge
then you'll go forward and create new
knowledge
fyman answered this question that i
didn't post but he said
uh i would put the atomic hypothesis
that everything's made of atoms
um and the further you subdivide uh
things it goes into atoms
now why i would put on my
uh my my um particular monolith
i would put the cosmic microwave
background because the cosmic microwave
background
is also in sense caused by the
properties of atoms
so it encodes more information it can be
seen from anywhere in the universe this
pattern
and it would also indicate that we
didn't know whether the universe had a
beginning or not
or maybe multiple beginnings so for
those reasons i would put that on there
along with a with a picture of my wife
because that would be kind of cool no
i'm just kidding
honey i love you all right last one is
the final question
and it actually owes itself to the
origin of my or my
podcast name goes itself to the origin
it comes from arthur c
clarke so arthur c clarke had many many
laws
uh one of which was any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and you
know kev i actually have his voice
saying those words and that's how i open
all my podcasts isn't that cool no
that's very cool
yeah his other law another one of his
laws is that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
kind of a little twist on what feynman
said
uh and then lastly he says the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the name of
the podcast into the impossible brian
keating
so i want to ask you kev kind of advice
to your former self
when you were 20 and you're not that old
now maybe you know 10 years ago whatever
what would you have told yourself to
give yourself the courage that you
needed
to go into the impossible and create
this empire that you're building that
you influence people that
you haven't met yet like such as myself
what would you tell your former self
in terms of life advice and i've gotten
all sorts of amazing answers but i want
to hear yours
you know i really again a really great
question man really good then
i look 20 20 odd years ago i was in the
military
and i was quite a shy guy didn't like
doing public speaking
and if somebody had told me then i'd be
doing this now i'd have laughed them off
the face of the earth i would have but i
would tell myself
just be confident be confident
and try and do things that make you feel
uncomfortable because they bring the
best rewards
you know anyone can sit and get
complacent and do the things that are
easy
but it's the things that really take out
your comfort zone they're the most
rewarding
i find now looking back that's when i've
learned the most
when i've approached subjects that are
really something
really alien to me no interest you know
when you go and look at that then
you actually find wow stuff in here that
is interesting so take that leap
i have a lot more confidence in yourself
and
like you say go into the impossible
because that's where the best stuff lies
that's right
that's a beautiful way to end it that
was awesome kev thank you so much for
all thank you for obliging and and then
kind of
being being game and humoring me at
least i like that on the spot type thing
i don't do scripting i prefer to have a
an organic conversation so that kind of
thing that's perfect brother perfect
that's awesome
thank you so much for having me on man
you missed you and you
will do it again maybe in a couple
months yeah if you've got one final
thing to say to the audience about
you know what's coming the rest of the
year a positive message brian what would
it be
yeah i would say that you want to look
to scientists
and you want to question scientists you
want to be like a scientist i don't know
another scientist who just says oh a
scientist said it let me just trust what
they have to say
think scientifically trust scientists
when you have a reason to trust
us but you have a stake in science
because
your financial uh contributions
enable your scientists in your country
scientists in my country
to do what we do we do it as a privilege
it's an honor to do it
we do it because there's no war going on
where you know governments would need to
co-opt our services
but there is an obligation of scientists
to
uh to to uh to to act ethically
to expose and and and reveal when they
don't know something
this is another favorite quote of mine
by feynman he said that
um he said he said that uh the first
principle is that you must not
fool yourself and the second principle
is that you're the easiest person to
fool
and after you have not fooled other
scientists yourself you can go on to not
fooling other scientists
and after that you cannot fool the
general public
doesn't mean that you shouldn't trust in
scientists i trust my life to scientists
every time i go out every time i get on
a plane every time i do
take a vaccine or whatever so definitely
by all means but think critically
demand uh answers that you can
understand you're totally entitled to it
and uh and and and b as as
uh as kev was saying be excellent to
each other
and uh and i think that for me this year
if we can do that i've got a but we have
a bunch of projects coming on
i hope we'll uh we'll be able to
reconvene again soon absolutely now
just for the listeners out there
remember to go and visit brian's website
and briankeating.com and also if you
haven't done so already please
please please get onto his youtube
channel right here
it's dr brian keating into the
impossible
new videos every tuesday and when can we
look forward to the audiobook coming out
brian real quickly for to let you go
yeah so hopefully the galileo audiobook
will be out this year and then my
other book think like a nobel prize
winner will be out
uh before the nobel prizes so in
september so basically yeah we have to
get together before then yeah
definitely brother thank you so much
you're not gonna want to miss it
all right have a great day
you